So auf gehts, kucken wir mal ob alles passt, ist auch was für ein Timelapse, das ist auch
was für ein Timing, oje die Kokomrits sind am Start sehe ich, wie heißen die chinesischen
Kokomrits, die heißen ja wohl nicht so, die haben da bestimmt auch irgendwas für, naja
übrigens habt ihr mitbekommen, es gibt jetzt, ich gleich mal zeigen, müssen wir kurz noch
was trinken ja, Säck, Mixcloud moin, nee nicht Mixcloud alter so zu viel, ich hab zu
viel Cloud gelesen, Mixsold oder so, genau Hetzner ist sehr laut, in zwei Wochen geht
es Hetzner sehr laut streamen und Hetzner sehr laut Video, ungefähr, top, also Leute
weiß nicht wie weit ihr das mitbekommen habt, es gibt jetzt ein Raspberry Pi Zero 2, ok
hat heißen schon vor zwei Tagen geschrieben oder so, hab ich nicht gesehen, irgendwie ist
das komplett unter Bradar bei mir, oh 15 Euro, na gut das ist ein Zero, die Dinger sind ja
auch billig, kosten ja auch bloß 15, also ich hab es überhaupt nicht mitbekommen, dass
es jetzt ein Raspberry Pi Zero 2 gibt und der Unterschied zum normalen Zero ist, alter
das ist aber auch schon krasser Kontrast hier, der Unterschied zum normalen Zero ist wohl,
dass es eine Raspberry Pi 3 CPU ist, also das spricht, irgendeine die 64bit kann und
wo zumindest das 64bit Raspberry Pi Ding drauf läuft, maximal eins pro Kunde, wo gibts denn
da welche, wo kann man die, ich mein Berry Base ist schon in Ordnung, ich hätt mir halt
gern gleich nen 5er Pack gekauft, zumindest ist es eine 64bit CPU und es ist vor allem
das wichtigste, gar nichtmal dass es eine 64bit CPU ist, das wichtigste ist, dass es jetzt
ein aktueller ARM, ne aktueller ARM CPU ist, was ist das ARM V8 oder so, V7, V8, V9 ich
weiß nicht, ist auch wurscht, zumindest da läuft jetzt alles normale drauf, also da
läuft auch ein.NET Core und sonst was drauf, nicht dieses Rumgefrickel, was nötig war
mit dem normalen Raspberry Pi, also das ist richtig heiß, genau das ist die CPU vom Raspberry
Pi 3, sag ich doch, das ist die CPU vom Raspberry Pi 3, er ist aber ein bisschen geringer getaktet
als der Raspberry Pi 3, ich glaub 1,3 Gigahertz hatte der Raspberry Pi 3, glaub der hat nur
eins, dass er wahrscheinlich nicht so heiß wird, aber im Prinzip ist es mehr oder weniger
ein Raspberry Pi 3 auf so nem kleinen Ding, das ist wirklich nice, das ist finde ich so
das optimale Ding, wenn es nen ESP32 oder nen ESP866 oder irgendein Arduino oder sonst
was, wenn es das einfach nicht, wie sagt man, nicht so schön cuttet, ja, also wenn du irgendwas
umfangreicheres brauchst, sei es sowohl leistungstechnisch vielleicht oder eben halt auch dass
du nen Linux drauf laufen hast, das ist so das Ding, was du nehmen kannst für alles,
wo es noch klein sein muss, aber wo du keinen Bock hast mit nem ESP rumzufrickeln.
Und was geht's, neuen Raspberry Pi, den es gibt seit zwei Tagen, muss man gucken, wo
kann man den jetzt schön kaufen, vielleicht nach Möglichkeit ja auch, dass man das sich
kaufen kann, ohne Beschränkung auf eine Person, was ist das hier, also der Dark Reader ist
broken grad, entweder ist das vielleicht auch so broken, aber das ist auch so broken, ok,
guck mal was sagt dein Geiz, halt's dazu, wo gibt's denn das alle, tja, ja der RAM ist
ein bisschen wenig, aber hey, ich will mal nicht meckern bei so nem kleinen Ding, naja,
also zum Beispiel, also vier CPU-Kerner sind an sich schon mal ganz praktisch, wenn du
irgendwas streamen willst, von irgendwelchen Kameras oder sonst wie, oder eventuell das
noch umencoden musst oder irgendwas, das ist jetzt nicht so häufig, aber eh, wir wollen
zwar nicht beschweren über mehr Rechenleistung, aber das eigentliche Gute ist, dass es ein
aktueller ARM-CPU ist, das ist das Wichtige, ob das jetzt eins oder zwei oder vier Kerne
sind, einer finde ich doof, aber sag mal ob das jetzt zwei oder vier Kerne sind ist egal,
aber das Wichtige ist, dass es der aktuelle ARM-CPU ist, wo alles drauf läuft, ich hab
vor zwei Jahren das bei AliExpress gekauft, das Päckchen kam an, tja, ehm, hier, hab
vor zwei, hab aber per Passwort meine E-Mail vergessen, hab deshalb noch nicht bezahlen
können, melden die sich von AliExpress irgendwann per Post, naja, also wenn du vor zwei Jahren
was bestellt hast, glaub ich, und da jetzt in der ganzen Zeit nichts gekommen ist, wird
jetzt auch nichts mehr kommen, lul, außerdem, wenn du noch nicht bezahlt hast, wie sollen
die das dann verschickt haben, Vorkasse machen die bei AliExpress ja nicht, daubt das hier,
ich, irgendwie kann ich mir nicht so ganz vorstellen, so, ab acht Angebote, das Ding,
es gibt den noch nur noch in Wireless, VeryBase, Reichelt, da hab ich immer einen Pack Widerstände
und irgendwie sowas bestellt für 50 Cent und hab drei, vier Euro Versand bezahlt, auch
nur eins pro Kunde, warum, was eben, Armboard, Armboard, wie viele darf man hier bestellen?
Da brauchen wir das, wie viel darf man hier bestellen, fünf, zwei, ok, ok, hier kann
man zwei bestellen, schon mal nice, ich mein, was man, leider haben die alle keinen kostenlosen
Versand, hätten die kostenlosen Versand, würde ich einfach bei fünf Shops jeweils
einen bestellen, ok, das ist jetzt aber zu teuer, da wirds jetzt aber wirklich zu teuer
langsam, auf Rechnung mein ich, ja was hab ich denn gesagt, ich mein, auf Rechnung,
nicht Vorkasse, lull ich hab Vorkasse gesagt, Schwachsinn, ja ja, auf Rechnung, aber Vorkasse
macht Aliexpress auch nicht, was soll das, Armboard, ja da kann man zwei Stück bestellen,
hier kann man einen Stück bestellen, ab fünfte, elfte und hier, die sind direkt sofort verfügbar,
was denn jetzt, wisst ihr, was wahrscheinlich bestell ich mein, was kosten der Kram denn
hier als Versand, ja das ging komplett an mir vorbei, dass es den jetzt gibt, das hab
ich vorhin gesehen, also da muss ich mir gleich kaufen, was kosten das bei den Versand, alter,
könnt ihr nicht einfach mal Versand, Versand, was kosten bei euch Versande, ich brauch
kein Raspberry Pi 3, ich hab selbst noch welche, das geht um den hier, explizit um den da,
nicht um irgendeinen, ok, das kostet doch mal vier Euro Versand obendrauf, sondern was
gibt es bei denen, zwei, zur Kasse, Versand, ja sag mal, wisst ihr wie mich Shops aufregen,
wo man nicht mal, wo man nicht mal eingeben kann, Postleitzahl, ok, 3,90, das geht sogar,
das geht sogar, ich glaub dann bestell, ich habe, ich wusste bis eben nicht, dass dieser
Shop existiert, aber ich mein, ist doch egal, mit was darf man denn bezahlen, mit was darf
man denn bezahlen bei diesem Laden, mein Gott, ist die Seite kacke, die Seite ist mega beschissen,
Zahlungsmöglichkeit, ja ok, PayPal, ja wunderbar, sag mal, hat irgendjemand einen Plan, warum
PayPal Checkout so selten ist, ich hab eben irgendwo PayPal Checkout, hier hab ich PayPal,
nee Amazon Pay und PayPal Checkout, gibt's so selten, dabei ist das eigentlich für mich
immer das angenehmste, weil PayPal Apis ein Hater sind, ja, das, das wird sein, hallo,
ah, da ist es schon, die Warenkorb, zur Kasse, die haben, die haben aber wenigstens PayPal
oder Amazon Pay Checkout, oder, also die Seite, die krackt ja mal voll ab, PayPal Checkout
oder Amazon, die zwei, die sind mir persönlich am liebsten, da brauch ich kein Login, da
brauch ich kein Zeug eingeben, da brauch ich keine Kundnummer eingeben, da melde ich mich
einfach mal PayPal an, nehmt die Bezahldaten von da an, die Anschrift von da an und gut
ist, easy, ey, danke für die Subs, Leute, Mario XTB und der Kitkat T, Poggers, exzellent,
reichen Lieferzeiten länger als Wish, was haben sie denn, ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt,
ach, 5.11, alter, was ist denn das für ein Track, für den Dragmann, ach, hier kann man
auch noch, eingeben, Versand ermitteln, dann bestell ich mir jetzt bei Armboard, ich hab
von dieser Seite noch nie was gehört, das ist wahrscheinlich voll chibate, ey, ich muss
sagen, mir geht es ehrlich gesagt nur ums haben, ich hab glaub ich noch 3 unbenutzte
Raspberry Pi Zeros rumfliegen, also war ja das Zeros rumfliegen und auch noch normal,
aber ich will das haben, weil neu, Poggers, alter, für ein Unreal Tournament Spiel, ja,
so ungefähr geht es mir mit Technikkram auch, ich hab so viel Kram, nee, nee, PayPal Checkout,
also PayPal Express ist relativ selten, PayPal selbst ist nicht das Problem, PayPal bezahlen
geht eigentlich bei den meisten, aber PayPal Express, PayPal Express Checkout oder dieses
PayPal Checkout ist halt das Gute daran, du musst keine Countdown machen und nix, du kannst
dich per PayPal einloggen, bei PayPal die Anschrift übertragen und per PayPal bezahlen,
das gibt es, das machen nicht so viele, wahrscheinlich weil es teurer ist, denke ich mal, genau,
ESP2866 muss ich heute auch kaufen, ja, nachdem ich ja meinen letzten D1 Mini irgendwie gegrillt
habe, ach, übrigens, Leute, ich hab's, ich hab's geschafft, wir haben doch im letzten
Stream versucht, so einen Teil hier, so einen Teil hier zu flaschen, ne, so was hier und
ich hab's, ich hab's kaputt gemacht, ich hab' Offstream nochmal ein bisschen rumgebastelt
einen Tag später und es hat geraucht und war kaputt, aber es war vorher auch schon kaputt,
ich gehe davon aus, dass entweder das Relay von Anfang an im Arsch war oder der Motor
irgendwas hatte, ich konnte das Ding nicht zum Funktionieren bewegen und irgendwann
hab ich mir gedacht, ey, weißt du was, muss man mal ein bisschen, ja, paar andere Kontakte
probieren und gucken, ob das Relay irgendwie, warum das nicht schaltet, da hab ich irgendwie
das falsche dran gehalten, dann hat's geraucht und war kaputt, hat richtig gestunken, muss
ich jetzt so eine halbe Stunde lüften danach, weil das hier das ganze Arbeitszimmer voll
geraucht hat, das Zeug, ne, ich schick das nicht zurück zu Amazon, ne, das hab ich nicht
gemacht, das würd ich auch nicht machen, allein schon, weil ich mir da zu viel Gedanken
mach, dass man sich mal irgendwann umbringt oder so, also 230 Volt hab ich kein Bock
drauf, da irgendwie dran rumzufuddeln, schon gar nicht, schon gar nicht bei so dünnen
Jumperkabeln oder so, ne, das mach ja nicht mal ich, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
wo wir mal die LED Beleuchtung gemacht haben, 5 Volt, 10 Ampere über Jumperkabel, wo das
halb geschmolzen ist, ja, ich auch, ich glaube, das will keiner rauchen, es sei denn, man
steht auf irgendwelche chemischen Plastikabgase, ja, das weiß ich noch nicht, aber ich hab
keine mehr, ich brauch unbedingt welche, also was ich brauche ist folgendes, also man braucht
ja immer mal welche, von LED-Ketten bis Chips austauschen bis irgendwie mal ein bisschen
rumprogrammieren, also ich brauch auf jeden Fall wieder mal nen Pack von denen, so 5er
Pack oder sowas in der Richtung, ja, was, XT, aber die Zeit, alter Leute, das ist zu
hell, ich muss dunkler machen, so, besser, so ein 5er Pack vielleicht, was ist denn der
Unterschied zwischen dem und dem, ah, das hier ist Fej, das ist Fej, ne, hä, was ist
denn da jetzt der Unterschied, ah, das hier sind Fake, das sind kompatible Fake-Dinger
oder so, ich mein, Abmaße und so sollten eigentlich komplett identisch sein, keine
Ahnung, China-Chinesen-Kram, ja, aber so ein 5er Pack könnte ich mir da mal wieder gönnen
hier, guck mal, hier kosten 3 Stück 10 Euro und hier kosten 5 Stück 16 Euro, was kosten
hier 5 Stück, 21, 18, ey, wenn, nachdem das eh alles Fake sind, nehm ich einfach den
5er Pack von XTVTX, was ist das, Moment, was, was ist das, ESP2, Mod, ist das, ist das
ein super, super Chebat, haben da die Chinesen von den Chinesen chinesische Sachen gefaked,
also haben die, haben die den Demon Mini gefaked und den ESP2 nach 66 gefaked, noch mal von
irgendeinem anderen Hersteller oder was ist das, die versenden, die hier scheinen auch
aus Deutschland zu versenden, wenn die bis Montag da sind, oder, ist das Montag, ah,
Dienstag, so, 5er Pack, das billigste vom billigsten, zack, wow, was hab ich denn da
doch alles im Basket von letztem Mal drille, warte, ne, brauch ich nicht, brauch ich nicht,
brauch ich nicht, brauch ich nicht, brauch ich nicht, hab, jetzt hab ich mir alle schon
gekauft, oh, next, ok, weiter, ja, also da, ich bestell mir hier einen einfach um ihn
zu haben, ich hab damit nix großartig vor, und was ich mir auch überlegt hab, was ich
mir kaufen sollte, sind ESP32, nackte ESP32, wow, warum ist das so teuer, normaler, das,
das bei China, das sind China aber billiger, ich mach mal kurz die VM an für China Kram,
weil es gibt ja immer mehr Geräte, die man nicht mal flashen kann, wo man den Chip austauschen
muss, aber die Chinesen sind nicht dumm, die Chinesen machen es nämlich so, dass die Chips
meistens pin-kompatibel sind, also sieht man ja auch zum Beispiel hier, W8BS, oder wie
hieß dieses Ding, W3BS, oder W, W, B, ach du scheiße, TASMOTA, W, W3S, ja, so, guckt,
das hier ist der neue Chip bei vielen China-Geräten und das ist der alte, der ist halt mehr oder
weniger pin-kompatibel, das heißt man kann bei ganz vielen einfach in Heißluft teilnehmen,
den alten Chip runter machen, den neuen wieder dran, oh ja, jetzt weiß ich, was ich unbedingt
wieder brauche, wie heißt es auf Deutsch, Flux, sowas da, zum Löten, Flussmittelstift,
sowas brauche ich unbedingt wieder, weil es lötet sich mit Flussmittel viel besser, das
hätte ich selbst nicht für möglich gehalten, der Unterschied ist echt extrem, also normalerweise
hat man ja in dem Lötzinn, also für den Heimgebrauch, in dem Lötzinn hast du ja innen
drinnen meistens ein bisschen Flussmittel, aber wenn man die Stellen vorher mit so einem
Stift abfluxst, dann ist das wirklich nice, also das fließt viel besser dran und du machst
auch keine Kurzschlüsse und sowas, das soll ich nehmen, warum, Chet, kennt man den Hersteller,
warum ruckelt mein Browser, seht ihr das, WTF, der Browser ruckelt beim scrollen, warum,
Moment Prozessexplorer gucken, ob da im Hintergrund irgendwas läuft, der China Bitcoin Miner ist
schon am Start, ich sehs schon, ich sehs schon, nee nix, pass mal auf so eine, oh Mist und
jetzt scroll ich mal, Alter, nee, ok jetzt mach ich das mal mit dem Originalchrome auf,
vielleicht ist das dann besser, zu wenig RAM, ja ich hab nur 32GB, das reicht nicht, im
Chrome ist super flüssig, ist das der Darkreader der rumspackt, Zack Darkreader off, das ist
der Darkreader, das ist der Darkreader, warum macht denn das der Darkreader so krass langsam
gerade, das ist ja, boah, Riesenunterschied, warum macht Darkreader das so langsam, ne,
versteh ich nicht, na gut, also Chet, warum soll ich mir diesen Stift kaufen, ist das
ein Hersteller den man kennt oder, bei dem Desktop kriegst du nen Anfall, das ist der
beste Desktop, Dom, Toretto, danke für den Sub, also ich find den Desktop der ist schon
äußerst ergonomisch, ich find alles was ich finden muss, wahrscheinlich, der Hersteller
ist gut, ok dann nehm ich das, mal gucken, kann sogar sein, dass ich genau den habe,
hatte, glaube, müsste ich meinen, ist egal, ich bestell jetzt einfach, sonst würd ich
mal in meiner Amazon-Historie nachgucken, aber ich glaube ich hatte genau den gleichen,
falls es den in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch in kleiner gibt, dann bin ich mir sogar
ziemlich sicher, dass ich den hatte, weil ich glaub so nen großen hatte ich nicht,
naja, so, Ed Basket, bam, oh, was möchte ich jetzt Amazon dann hier empfehlen, discover
additional products, Amazon commercial, Moment, Amazon hat jetzt nicht nur Amazon basic, Amazon
hat jetzt auch Amazon commercial, WS2812 brauch ich nicht, da hab ich noch genug davon, da
hab ich, da hab ich noch genug davon, ach Moment, das hab ich verwechselt, ich dachte
du meinst diese DSD, du meinst diese Temperatursensor, ne, du meinst LED, LED-Streifen, ne, ich hab's
grad durch die Hand gebracht, aber LED-Streifen hab ich tatsächlich auch noch welche da,
Amazon commercial, na, wenn Amazon das meint, bald kommt Amazon enterprise, ja, ja wunderbar,
ok, da haben wir das schon mal, so jetzt hat Amazon einmalig die Gelegenheit mich zu inspirieren
noch mehr Zeug zu kaufen, Moment, ich wollte, ich wollte ESP32 Module haben, ESP266 einfach
nur die nackten Module, die sind hier aber ein bisschen zu teuer, ich mein das kann ja
nicht sein, dass ich für die nackten Module mehr bezahle als wenn die auf nem Board drauf
sind, außerdem kostet der normalerweise 1 Euro oder so in China, Wolle, Dankeschön
für den Zap, so, mal die VM anmachen, für Aliexpress, Aliexpress wird nur aus der VM
gesurft, man weiß ja nie was die Commodits da so treiben, ach ja, und wer mich fragt
was das für ein Hintergrundbild ist, keine Ahnung, das ist Big Image of the Day, warum
ist mein Rofi eigentlich auf einmal jetzt hell, was soll das, also Aliexpress, ja, die
sind mittlerweile da, ESP12F, der Unterschied zwischen ESP12F und 12E by the way ist einfach
nur die Anordnung von der Antenne, guck, das ist nur die Antennen Anordnung ist ein
bisschen unterschiedlich, das hier ist glaub ich ein ticken neuer, ist ein bisschen besser,
aber, ach das ist, wer sich schon immer mal gefragt hat was diese Würmer hier nebendran
sind, das ist die WLAN Antenne, was wir kaufen, ich kauf mir ein paar ESP12 Module, guck mal,
wie kostet der Kram inklusive Flasher, 166, ne, das ist nicht das Modul, das ist das Modul
auf irgendeinem komischen Chip drauf, ist das Modul Einzel oder ist das Modul auf nem Flash
Ding drauf, kann man das abnehmen und ist das unten drunter einfach nur zum Flaschen oder
ist das da drauf, das check ich jetzt nicht, serielle, witzigen Wolkenentwicklung, die
Chinesen, Alter, die Aliexpress Übersetzung ist wieder on point, gehört zusammen, das
heißt die sind zusammen gelötet oder das, weil ich erkenne das, ich erkenne das hier
wirklich nicht, ok, wir gucken uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt gerade mal Sprache auf,
vielleicht die englische Übersetzung besser, serielle, witzigen, nein, warum ist denn das
so teuer, ja, wollte ich grad sagen, normalerweise kostet das ungefähr den Kram hier, ne, so
1 Euro, was denn das, in Weiß gibt, ne, das ist in Board, was auch immer das sein soll
zum Flaschen oder so, ja, das Modul brauch ich, genau, 125, 10 Stück, 20 Stück, ab wann
geht denn die, der Versand hoch, Alter, die Chinesen, ah hier, ab jetzt geht der Versand
hoch, ab 60, ab 60 geht der Versand hoch, 60 will ich dann doch nicht haben, wobei, wisst
ihr was halt der Witz ist, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr was der Witz ist, ich bezahle einfach
mal irgendwie 80 Euro oder so, ne, oder irgendwie, was ist denn 60, 60 mal, 75 Euro, 75 Euro
bei Amazon hätt ich irgendwie 5000 oder was weiß ich, was man bezahlt, nein 60 sind auch
mir ein bisschen zu viel des guten, was gibt's denn für Versandoptions, also, sag mal so,
stellen wir mal 20, die Dinger ist ja wirklich Wegwerfware, selbst wenn man das mal kaputt
macht, wow, vielleicht nicht so der beste Versand, also 220 Aliexpress Standard, 26.
November, gibt's da nicht noch irgendwas anderes, ok, jetzt kommt Aliexpress Master Race Skill
Suche, genau, man muss EU Warenlager, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht, natürlich dumm.
Ach ja, hat mal jemand sowas hier ausprobiert, so ein Programmer, ne, das ist gar kein Programmer,
das ist ein Entwicklerboard, wie man, also, wie würdet ihr die programmieren, ich glaube,
also man kann natürlich dranlöten, aber das ist glaube ich abfuck hoch 10, irgend so ein
Flasherboard wäre glaube ich am besten, wo du das denn reinklipst, Schiff aus, ah, Schiff
aus, kann man EU oder so auswählen, ne, Schiff aus Germany, Schiff aus United Kingdom, Spanien,
Frankreich, Russland, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich,
Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich, Frankreich,
1,40 Polen Hä?
Was?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn!
Warum ist ver- What the fuck?
Das ist doch Chebat oder?
Ja meinetwegen 5 Euro Versand ist ja N- Aber warum?
Aber Hä?
What?
D- Das ergibt absolut keinen Sinn!
Warum kostet das- also wa- also erstens warum ist es teurer?
Ok, aber warum ist es von Deutschland nach Deutschland länger als von China nach Deutschland?
ne ESP32 ist komplett was anderes ja wieso hä wie kommt ihr drauf ich weiß schon nach
was ich suche ach du meinst weil die ESP12 eingegangen haben ne das Modul heißt so das
Modul also der ESP82 das ist ein ESP82 66 das Modul heißt ESP12F oder ESP12E ja aus
china januar aber das andere ist billiger ok das das fest ich wollte mal wahrscheinlich
schieb wahrscheinlich schicken die das erst nach deutschland aus china und wenn ich fünf
euro ausgeben china alter ok scheiß drauf ach guck mal hier ist noch billiger ach das ist
erst nutzerpreis gbated also das scheint eigentlich ganz sinnvoll zu sein ja 26 november ich mein hey
das ist ja im prinzip nur noch einen monat wir gucken mal was banggood macht die haben bestimmt
auch welche bei banggood bestes seid ich muss das eingeblendet lassen während wir banggood
auf haben esp12 die haben gar keine module ach guck mal das ist in den flasher ne genau
sowas sowas sowas ist cool da steckste das rein kannst du das flashen und das mal gucken ob
sowas bei amazon gibt oder man muss doch bei amazon irgendwas halbwegs 20 euro man für 20
euro kann ich mir kann ich mir in china 15 stück bestellen oder so das sind fünf stück
also das ist was ist mit ihnen los woops soll ich jetzt gerade anklinken nach was jemand eine
ahnung nach was ich suchen kann dass ich so ach hier so ein bord genau sowas da bräuchte ich das
wäre doch tatsächlich ganz cool was ist wenn ich auf esp12 f sucht da findest du die kleinen
module alle das ist aber mega teuer bei amazon alles na gut die schiller chinesen wollen was
verdienen ich glaube es geht los aber die bords sind tatsächlich ganz praktisch aus
für 20 euro kriegst du auch noch ein ebook jawoll okay da kostet der gleiche kram warum
ist das hier alles so teuer man bei aliexpress kostet also ich soll es vielleicht mal auf euro
umstellen das ist auf euro moment sind wir auf banggood wie viel sind das
zehn stück was ist denn mit euch los warum sind die chinesen so teuer gerade gut dann
ist aliexpress eins eins 25 wird es jetzt 125 so und jetzt gucken wir mal bei dem im store
bei beim i texen store ob da noch flasher hat dafür das nehme ich gleich mit beim i texen
die china chinesen das ist nur das adapter board oder das ist nur
steuern auf deutsch würde das heißen ich besteuern die ich besteuern die ist natürlich
auch kein schlechter name keine ahnung das kaufe ich mir lieber hier bei amazon hier
blick der hat doch davon könnte ich auch welche gebrauchen noch wieder das ist luftfeuchtigkeit
und temperatur und luftdrucksensor wobei sieben euro glaube ich moment das ist irgendwas
nicht der hier den da unten mein ich den klein den klein aber sieben euro erscheint mir ein
jaja ich habe aber das ist ein anderer shop den er gepostet hat im chat die sind nämlich
richtig gut die dinger davon könnte ich auch wieder so ein fünfer pack gebrauchen egal
kauf auf gar keinen fall das als delivery nv modul was für ein ding nv modul als delivery
warum nicht das da was das das ist rund
ist das china mikrofon gleich mit drauf ich glaube das ist dass der dass das chinesische
geheimdienst gleich hier direkt mit am start ist ach nee das ist kein mikrofon das ist
ein luft so feinstaubsensor jetzt erkenne ich das heute ist ja alles zu teuer ich sehe
es nicht ein für ein euro 20 dinger bei aliexpress in amazon 10 euro zu bezahlen also ich kaufe
mir davon jetzt einfach 20 stück 20 stück beim einkauf fahren auf geht's moment moment
sekunde guck mal was was sehe ich denn hier akibatet das kostet genau die chinesen man
was willst du mit 20 stück bauen gar nichts ich will die haben weil immer mehr geräte
nicht mit einem esp kommen aber pinn kompatibel sind das heißt heißluft drauf raus und den
drauf machen und einfach dass ich nicht jedes mal was bestellen muss ihr wisst ich bestelle
nie einzeln ich bestell meistens meistens eins oder drei drei oder fünf und es hat
sich jetzt schon wieder also chat ihr habt bestes beispiel letzter stream letzter stream
hier mit mit diesem automatischen hebel umschalter so ich habe mir eingekauft und was ist passiert
er ist kaputt hätte ich drei bestellt hätte ich noch welche zum weitermachen ich bestelle
mir da jetzt einfach wieder welche bm es ist teurer geworden sei das letzte mal das
ist das ist drei vier euro teuer geworden seit letztem mal new from letzter stream hat
mir auch der esp gefällt genau na gut da hätte ich auch in dem und mini noch ins gehäuse
gekriegt da soll ich bestell das ding jetzt hier einfach zack ein auswand was haben wir
da noch drinnen brauche ich nicht mehr brauche ich nicht mehr weg habe ich schon bestellt
weg und die müssen wir auch flaschen demnächst mit der sind schon da zack wird bestellt was
ist das eigentlich 1111 also alle es ist ja manchmal ist aliexpress so voll mit irgendwelchen
random anzeigen du hast absolut keine ahnung was die von dir wollen kostet es am 11.11.
plus 120 oder was was wollen die uns sagen du hattest doch mal so eine coole selbst gedruckte
lampe mit leds drin ja die kannst du auch nachbauen und zwar das anleitungsvideo ist
das da das da guckt da sieht man es auch schön ja wenn die rabatte das macht schon was aus
ich meine 3 cent bei einem ding wurde eine wo manche leute irgendwie 20.000 stück kaufen
ja exakt so sieht es bei mir auch aus habt ihr ja gesehen ich finde es sieht wirklich
nice aus warum nutzt du die amazon rabatte nicht keine ahnung weil ich nicht mal sehe
wo es da welche gibt wo gibt es da welche auf der lampe läuft led klar garantiert läuft
der led drauf so also das habe ich das bestellt moment moment da wieder anmachen exzellent
so als haben wir das bestellt spm auch bestellt als esp module haben wir bestellt die die
5 d1 minis die man immer auch immer mal gebrauchen kann haben wir bestellt gibt es hier noch
auch mal nicht 10 prozent bei unter preis weiß nicht wo ach hier ja ja das ist die
bade da muss irgendwas für abschließen oder so da kannst du da kannst du dann in den
mist den ich das scheiß drauf brauche man hat das macht sein ist da auch nicht fett
ja gut aber dass ich das rein machen kann muss ich ja eingeloggt sein das mache ich
jetzt hier nicht und streben gut so das haben wir next was was empfiehlt uns denn aliexpress
heute mal gucken vielleicht ist ja vielleicht hat ja aliexpress irgendwas mal auf der startseite
wo ich denke das will ich haben ich habe noch nie noch nie was bei aliexpress gefunden
einfach so was ich haben will also da können die sich ohne das war eine schlechte idee
das war eine ganz schlechte idee benachrichtigung zulassen von aliexpress sec settings history
clear history letzte stunde jawohl benachrichtigung zulassen von aliexpress ist ganz ganz schlecht
was habe ich denn jetzt angeklickt man aliexpress ist schlimm heute da habe ich glück dass
der wagenkorb noch da ist weil jetzt ist er weil hier ist er jetzt weg weil ich weil
ich meine cookies gelöscht habe also 20 stück
ja aliexpress suche ist richtig mies habe ich jetzt vergessen wagenkorb zu legen oder
was chinesen shop das teilweise ganz grausam gemacht in den einkaufswagen habe ich doch
so also aliexpress nicht zulassen was empfiehlt ihr uns denn heute du kannst ja auch über
aliexpress hast du an jeder ecke irgendwas zum anklicken und sonst wie mal ganz im ernst
für jemand der da noch nie bestellt hat wenn man jetzt überlegt ich bin jetzt deutsche
hausfrau oder so und ich gehe auf aliexpress und sie ist diese seite du denkst doch instant
an scam oder also niemand hält die also niemand von hier hält diese seite für seriös wenn
er dies erste mal sieht das sieht das sieht einfach alle so nach nach china scam aus aber
ist es nicht ich hatte mit aliexpress bisher eigentlich immer nur gute erfahrung es sieht
auch einfach aus wie scam haferlängerung und perücken genau das das was ich jetzt gebraucht
habe damenhaus schuhe ja auch auch unbedingt manchmal erkennst du gar nicht was es ist
auf den bildern was ist das die wollen wir doch nicht wirklich erzählen dass ich für
19 euro irgendein smartwatch kriege die die das das produkt gibt es einfach nicht einfach
nicht existent hier liege liege 2021 alles klar 19 euro das ist mit sicherheit ein ganz
absolutes top produkt ja die chinesen so deine mutter hat die echt die die liege 2021 so
was was empfehlen die uns startkit für arduino die dinger sind teilweise gar nicht schlecht
bei aliexpress wenn man gerne bastelt nicht unbedingt wegen den wegen den arduinos die
finde ich seit es ps gibt eher weniger interessant aber die kids sind teilweise ganz lustig
zum basteln weil da von jedem app ist dabei ist ich meine ich brauch es nicht ich habe
mehr oder weniger alles in größere ausführungen da es ist aber billig scheiß also dreimal
das kabel um die ecke gesteckt und das ist die isolierung aufgebrochen ist halt schon
ziemlicher müll tiefewelleverschluss meine güte sie jetzt zum fürchten aus bei aliexpress
heute wieder early kong an ihr ihr kong der ihr kong möchte ich wirklich einen aliexpress
rauch melde haben ich weiß nicht was meint ihr chat kann man dem sache kann man der sache
trauen oder nicht am ende des tages kommen alle rauch melde
aus china nähe gerade bei rauch melden gibt es tatsächlich ganz gute deutsche herrschaft
frag mich nicht welch wie die jetzt heißen aus dem kopf aber ich habe auch keine von
china das ding ist in deutschland eh nicht zugelassen naja mich kann ja keiner dran
hindern das an die decke zu hängen aber es ist keine so gute idee aha so geht es also
detect smoke detector trigger wifi router wifi router alarm aufs handy und dann rufe ich
die feuerwehr an ach so na gut nope dass jetzt die schelle das sonn auf schelle verschnitt
plus dass die schelle ist eigentlich deutlich angenehmer zu benutzen sind bestell mal und
teste die nicht habe so viel sinnlose sachen schon bestellt die hier wenn du wirst dass
ich habe riesen berge technik rams hier liegen den ich nie brauchen werde oh ein 8 euro löd
kolben jawoll huge jawoll das ist bestimmt dass das ist das was man benutzen möchte
guck mal du kriegst für 18 euro ein set mit allem dabei unten im löd kolben das ist bestimmt
qualitativ absolut erste sahne da kann man eine erste lödstation einpacken was kostet
so ein halbwegs guter lödkolben naja für kleine elektronikteile finde ich bietet sich
das tatsächlich an entweder man nimmt ein bisschen von den kleineren oder man nimmt
eine lödstation die halt heizt und also was die die das netzteil drinne hat und die einstellung
und auf der anderen seite hat man halt ein kabel mit dem kleinen lödkolben ja die t-s
die t-s 80 t-s 100 der soll wirklich ganz gut sein habe ich auch schon gehört tragbare
elektrischer wasserkocher was für unsinnige sachen es gibt oh eine ssd von golden 4 hat
irgendjemand schon von diesem hersteller gehört was ist golden 4 das kann auch golden 4 heißen
also da hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch angst wenn ich die china ssd verwende so aus china
die ein terabyte variante moment eben war es noch bei 12 euro das kriegst du das kannst
du dir aber noch bei amazon die auch kaufen für den für das geld kinder led projektor
genau auf geht's für den chat das zeug das stinkt wahrscheinlich so sehr dass es drei
wochen erst mal raus stellen muss dass das überhaupt dran denken kannst ins kinderzimmer
zu stellen drill pro dremel beide weichnessen hat euch schon mal jemand gesagt dass dremel
eigentlich der hersteller ist also egal gekonert alles klar nicht dass ich mir das kaufen will
ich will mir nix davon kaufen ich möchte aliexpress nur mal die chance geben mir irgendwas
fortzuschlagen was ich kaufen will weil bisher hatte ich es noch nie wirklich also ich bin
immer nur auf aliexpress wenn ich schon vorher wusste was ich kaufen will aliexpress hat
es noch nie geschafft wirklich noch nie nicht einmal dass ich mir durch die empfehlung irgendwas
gekauft habe bei amazon kommt es öfters mal vor aber bei aliexpress und aber das ist auch
painstab das ist so komplett aliexpress habe ich den eindruck die kleistern dich einfach
random mit fünf millionen produkten zu die zum größten teil einfach nur maximal unsinnig
sind surefire für akkus ja das ist vielleicht keine so gute idee alter das sieht ja zum
fürchten aus das vor allem das guck mal wie random meist ist das eigentlich laserentfernungsmesser
übrigens so ein komisches willi schiener den habe ich mir mal gekauft das hat gemessen
zum dach denken alle ich komme aus russland ich habe gemessen vom boden zum dach es waren
irgendwie einmal keine ahnung 650 und einmal sieben meter zwanzig obwohl ich nicht bewegt
habe also bei den chinesen ist die lichtgeschwindigkeit auch variabel wenn das wirklich nur ein cent
kostet dann ist das ein super angebot aber das ist jebait das kostet nicht nur ein cent
was genau soll hier jetzt ein cent kosten was was was nichts davon kostet nur ein cent
nichts die chinesen mann warum ist das so ein beschiss wieder ich meine es ist ja kein
beschiss man sieht ja vorher man sieht ja vorher vor allem das ist viel zu teuer für den kram
die gibt es teilweise deutlich billiger die aquara sentron oh mann da könnte man sich
aber tatsächlich mal wieder ein paar von kaufen auf der anderen seite bräuchte ich brauche
ich die nicht weil ich habe zum größten zweif tür und fenster melder schwachsinn ok aliexpress
ist heute nicht so der wahnsinn was hat ein bengut in den empfehlungen drinnen bengut
der gleiche schwachsinn wie bei aliexpress ey die china shops sind so voller schrott
aber es ist gut ganz ehrlich wenn man weiß was man haben will man bekommt die sachen dort
einfach unglaublich günstig so also haben wir bestellt ich muss jetzt mal kurz in meine
in meine liste gucken dort irgendwie mal ein paar spannende sachen aufgeschrieben habe
die ich brauche was heißt spannend das hört ihr jetzt wie ja doch tatsächlich ich habe
was aufgeschrieben was ich noch brauche ich brauche mal wieder so ein wago klemmen set
also man könnte natürlich auch mal eine komplette man könnte natürlich auch mal eine komplette
dose kaufen 2 oder 3 oder so aber ich finde dieses setzt ziemlich praktisch weil man wenn
man nicht so viel braucht dann es lohnt sich halt nicht irgendwie 503 oder 502 oder 504
oder so zu haben da reichen keine ahnung 20 von jeder sorte 20 30 von jeder sorte aber
hat immer welche wenn man welche bräuchte warum ist es so teuer ja also bei denen geht's
finde ich bei den alten da konnte man sich ziemlich den finger klemmen mit bei diesen
grauen ja bei denen da bei denen konnte man sich noch ziemlich die finger klemmen das
musstest du nämlich hoch machen reinstecken und dann musstest du quasi das runter machen
und da hast du halt oftmals zu so mit dem daumen dagegen gedrückt dass dann hier noch
drunter was und die dinger haben ganz schönen feder federung oder zug drinne also wende
dort wende dort das zu macht also ist das das klatscht ganz schön runter im alten haben
die leute immer sich was das die haben jetzt auch so was ja das ist pock das brauche ich
wie oft hatte ich schon das problem dass ich mal kabel miteinander verbinden will aber
sie wieder lösen können möchte gut ich meine wenn man es ganz eklig macht man kann auch
einfach in so eine wago klemme dann zwei aber so diese durchgangsdinger das ist das ist cool
die hier sind die sind nicht für starre leitungen die gelben sind für starre leitungen die hier
gehen für beides soweit ich weiß also die hier gehen für starre also komplette und und
für wie heißt das litzen glaube ich na die hier die hier sind für die gelbe die gelbe
sind für feste feste adern so brauche ich set set 105 ne ist das eigentlich so teuer
was ist das da vorne rechts und wahrscheinlich mit hebel können beides ohne hebel sind für
starre ja genau ja sag ich doch hier guck die da die sind also gerade die also die gut
ja die hier wahrscheinlich auch aber bei den gelben weiß ich dass die nur für die habe
ich schon mal benutzt dass die für starre sind ja was nehme ich denn da jetzt irgendwie
mal ans set hier ist auch alles mögliche drin oder oder sind ne das sind wie viele
sind das jetzt set 25 mal das ach jeweils 25 mal also 25 mal ähm kleine das ist eigentlich
ganz gut das könnte man sich tatsächlich mal geben welche zahlungsmethode nutze man
eigentlich so gut wie immer paypal ich habe früher mal alipay benutzt hat hat hat jemand
von euch mal äh erfahrung machen dürfen mit alipay vor allem zu zeiten als der kram
noch komplett in chinesisch war wo du mit google translator den kram übersetzen musstest
alipay ist wirklich nicht schön kann ich euch sagen ok das ist da ist da ist ja nix
was ist fünf stück von jedem oder was das ist ja crap und die kabelbinder braucht kein
mensch ich kaufe mir wirklich bald einfach einen guck mal hier kriegst du den kompletten
hier kriegste komplett zwei äh dreier und und was das fünfer oder so was ist denn mit
so einem set hier ich glaube das habe ich gerade ich glaube das bestelle ich wieder
weil ich mir einbildet das war ein bisschen günstiger da hast du glaub 20 stück von
jedem oder sowas 20 stück ah nee du hast unterschiedlich viele genau weil du brauchst
ja mehr davon also brauchst ja du brauchst ja im prinzip eher ähm mehr von den kleinen
als von den ganz großen einfach influencer reviewer werden ja genau das ist das komm
hier wieder so ein set gut ist auf jeden fall wieder welche die dinger kannst du wirklich
für alles gebrauchen so ich gucke mal kurz chat ob sie irgendwas übersehen habe ja
ich habe mich auch angemeldet weil man es brauchte ach das sind die hutschienenhalter
na ok ne das brauche ich nicht ja kann man auch machen heißkleber ist eh so ein universal
ding also ich muss sagen die heiß also die ähm ich hab ja so ein heißkleber so ein
Teil ich hab das früher nicht für notwendig gehalten ups oh das ist billy schiener zeuche
wobei keine ahnung sagt mir nix ähm ich hab es früher nicht für möglich gehalten
dass man eine dass man heißkleber braucht aber seit ich heißkleber habe leute ich sag
euch heißkleber kann man für alles verwenden und heißkleber funktioniert auch einfach
bei fast allem einfach es gibt kaum was was man nicht irgendwie lösen kann durch ordentlich
große portion heißkleber da können sämtliche klebe bänder sekundenkleber oder andere dinger
einpacken einfach ordentliche portion heißkleber drauf drücken zusammen drücken dran drücken
was auch immer kurz warten und das ding ist fest also ich hab bisher mit heißkleber wirklich
nur äh gute erfahrungen gemacht gibt bestimmt auch andere sachen die gut funktionieren
einfach abgetrennte körperteile mit heißkleber wahrscheinlich geht sogar das hast du dir
den finger abgeschnitten und du klebst ihn einfach wieder dran wobei das tatsächlich
funktionieren könnte wenn du wenn ich komplett durch ist aber halt nicht im drinnen ankleben
sondern außen drum herum ankleben sodass es noch wieder aufeinander ist es könnte
vielleicht echt funktionieren solange noch blut durchgeht ansonsten ich hab mir früher
mal in so einem kurs also in so einem hilfekurs gemacht da hat mir jemand erzählt man soll
wenn man sich den finger abgeschnitten hat den finger also man soll man soll den den
den notarzt rufen oder so schnell wie möglich ins krankenhaus und man soll den finger suchen
und den mund stecken dass das irgendwie desinfiziert ist oder so also man soll den finger quasi
im mund stecken und dann ins krankenhaus so fahren wobei ich glaube die wenigsten leute
möchten ihren finger im mund stecken haben wobei man ganz davon abgesehen keine ahnung
ob das noch aktuell ist hat mir zumindest mal jemand erzählt dass man das so machen
soll ab ist ab naja die frage ist ja wahrscheinlich eher wie gut du das wieder dran kriegst kühlen
doch nicht in den mund hat gesagt kühlen er hat gesagt den mund stecken nicht kühlen
hat gesagt den mund stecken finger im mund stecken weil das glaube ich blöd ist wenn
man den finger in den mund steckt bevor man beim krankenhaus anruft kühlen klingt für
mich auch sinnvoller aber er hat gesagt in den mund stecken so ja das wollen wir ja
nicht aber hör mal auf warum flashbang uns das immer so so also das haben wir jetzt auch
schon bestellt
ich kann nicht alles reviewen was ich mir kaufen will
china gadgets hat mal gesagt dass man bei banggood super handys kaufen kann ja kann ich mir vorstellen
den programmer habe ich nicht den kaufe ich mir dann wenn das zeug da ist bei amazon oder
so ja das stimmt
also vieles dieser china marketplace dinger ist irgendwelche dropship geschichten aber
besser bei amazon dropshippen lassen als bei wish oder wish wish ist auch so eine absolute
sinnlos plattform
hey max glaubst du es gibt ein unterschied zwischen lampen die man auf aliexpress und
co findet eins zu eins von den bilden die man selbst
denselben die man bei europäische zuviel nee das ist das ist china graben zum größten
teil alles im besten fall haben die rebrandet mit
irgendwas anderem das ist genauso wie wenn du bei amazon guckst und dir beispielsweise
wlan steckdosen kaufst da findest du 20 mal die gleiche steckdose unter einem anderen
namen mit diesen typischen china shops übrigens wo wir gerade dabei sind gibt es wieder gibt
es gibt es steckdosen leiste die man flaschen kann
die bestimmt nicht die ist doch nicht wlan mäßig
meine eltern sind auch wish rein gefallen das stand lager verkauft wie kann man auch
wish reinfallen also bei wish muss man ja schon drauf gehen um sich aktiv scammen zu
lassen ich verstehe es nicht gerade hat also man muss auch sagen wish wish eilt ja auch
ihr ruft voraus hat irgendjemand eine ahnung warum ich überhaupt noch da ist ich meine
langsam muss ich das doch rumgesprochen haben dass es eigentlich zum größten teil schrott
ist ja das stimmt kifke leiche für den snap 22 monate poggers so ähm das ist so schlimm
mit diesen du bist hier immer so geflasht bangt hammer steckdosen leiste wifil ich gib
es da wieder irgendwas flaschbares china chinesen flaschbare
weil ich habe alle jetzt verbaut ich habe im keller einstehen ich habe auf meinem rechner
einstehen für die switcher und krams ich habe auf dem basteltisch einstehen und ich
habe im ich glaube nicht ja alle alle kugel steckdosen leisten sind verbaut ich brauche
neue beispiel zu den namten nova luci was nova luci das klingt wie irgendwie die only
die onlyfans seite von irgendeinem streamer grill nova luci das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen
was er nova luci oder so ist lampe da zeigt mal her aber vielleicht für die sehen jetzt
eigentlich nicht so aus als haben die auf aliexpress was ich meine es kann natürlich sein dass
die reprinten den kram wobei das schon für mich so aussieht als würden die eigenen kram
machen die chinesen kopieren aber ganz gerne mal erfolgreiche sachen das sieht für mich
jetzt nicht nach typischem aliexpress reprint kram aus
vielleicht haben sie chinesen einfach nur kopiert oder aber es ist wirklich aliexpress
reprinting weiß man ja nie such mal modern kronleuchte auf aliexpress also wenn die dinger
beliebt sind haben die chinesen das garantiert kopiert gehe ich mal von aus also das kriegen
die immer ganz gut hin zu gucken welche produkte sind erfolgreich und dann gibt sie dann auch
demnächst auf aliexpress aber halt meistens dann nicht so genau verstanden was die produkte
eigentlich gut macht das ist ja alles riesengroß das täuscht warum gibt es nicht mehr die
gute alte kogeek steckdosenleiste die war gut kogeek smart plug steckdosenleiste ja
die ne die auch nicht die kogeek steckdosenleiste nein nein nein nein nein die original dina
die war gut die konnte man noch das motor flaschen over the air die hatte vier stecker
und firma usb die war einfach poggers ich hätte mir damals einen zener pack kaufen
sollen als als ich festgestellt habe die war flashbar aber glaubst du nicht die produkte
also bei dem hersteller sieht es mir nicht nach typischem aliexpress rebranding aus nee
aber bei wlan lampen oder so da ist es auf jeden fall so welchen vorteil hat das eine
steckdosenleiste zu flaschen das habe ich jetzt zwar schon 30 trillionen mal erzählt
aber es war natürlich nicht jeder da weil du dann keine china app brauchst und keine
china cloud damit sie funktioniert und du sie besser mit normalen standards in deine
heim automatisierung einbinden kannst wie gesagt ganz ohne china cloud oder komische
china app die war gut die würde ich mir die würde ich mir auch wieder kaufen aber die
gibt es nicht ah guck mal da hammer moment resale hammer jetzt auf einmal aliexpress auch
ja das ist eindeutig die gleiche stelle das ist so ein typisches china rebranding ding
alles das gleiche alter was ist mit der musik gerade los krieg der dresd ab hier muss man
kurz was anderes anmachen hammer ja das ist aliexpress rebranded eins zu eins aber die
kann man bestimmt nicht mal flaschen und außerdem sind sind 36 euro viel zu viel aber wie gesagt
da habe ich schon welche hier und die waren echt gut als man die noch flaschen kann anscheinend
gibt es es aber nicht mehr ziemlich sagt der was gibt es noch flaschbare steckdosenleisten
feuerlust gucken wir mal gucken wir mal in den kommentaren was es da noch gibt ist das
ok ich suche jetzt einfach nach alexa da findet man mehr essentials ok 29 ist gerade noch
so verkraftbar
der name das ist so ein typischer typischer china name wenn sie europäisch klingen wollen
da gibt es total viele in dieser richte guck maxiko die wenn willst mehr aus das ist alles
china kram komplett alles china kram aber die versuchen halt immer so ein bisschen europäisch
zu klingen das hat ja gute bewährdung konfiguration unmöglich anzeige ist raus ja ich kenne die
seite aber dann weißt du immer noch nicht was davon gerade lieferbar ist die einträge
von der seite sind ja teilweise 23 jahre alt also ich habe es bisher immer umgedreht
gemacht bei amazon geguckt in den bewertungen geguckt und dann geguckt ob es irgendwie templates
gibt fertige ok es gibt anscheinend wirklich nicht viel gerade zehnfach steckdose ok jetzt
wird aber etwas ist es auch wlan gogo tool die gogo tool steckdosenleiste ist das wlan
muss ja hat er keine schalter oder ach so die ist einfach alles an einfach immer alles
an ok ne das ist keine das ist keine wlan man so eine 10er wlan steckdose das wäre
doch mal was kann man das flaschen das ding amazon ich weiß nicht ob da ein
und was sollen diese warum sind diese antworten bei amazon eigentlich immer so unsinnig irgendjemand
fragt was und die antwort ist da drauf ich weiß es nicht so genau warum antwortet man
denn da drauf ich verstehe es nicht wo ist denn der sinn
das ding zu flaschen nein es wird kein verbrauch tägliche anweisung
das mutter nicht mehr das mutter fähig es ist wirklich schwierig was flaschbares zu
finden aktuell muss man sagen deswegen genau deswegen habe ich mir den kram hier bestellt
also hatte er vorhin jemand gefragt warum will man sowas haben genau deswegen ja warum
ist man warum ist man aliexpress wahrenkorb schon wieder leer warum ist der wahrenkorb
schon wieder leer die chinesen so das ist der grund warum ich mir davon 20 stück kaufen
wollte weil du kannst in der regel wenn man sich solche steckdosenleisten kauft und da
ist kein esp mehr drinne dann kann man meistens den chip eins zu eins austauschen eben gegen
den anderen meistens sind die dinger pinn kompatibel deswegen will ich davon 20 stück
haben guck mal was der versand kostet sind es nicht die die vorher auch hatten die hatten
wir vorhin die hatten wir vorhin das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau ich glaube das sind
zwei sachen also das sind ja mehrere stufen der herrscht also der hersteller dieser leisten
ist ja nicht der der sie verkauft ich glaube die reseller mögen das nicht dass man sie
flaschen kann die reseller und das andere ist dass die dieser tuja hersteller der also
dieses ganze tuja zeug macht mittlerweile andere chips verwendet als ein esp 32 oder
ein esp 82 66 das heißt die müssen gar nicht aktiv verbieten dass man das flaschen kann
es gibt einfach keine custom firme dafür das hat sich noch nie jemand damit beschäftigt
mit diesen neuen realtek cpus ich glaube die reseller die wollen dass man ihre apps verwendet
anders kann ich ansonsten verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht ich bin da auch ein bisschen
ratlos warum man das verbietet keine ahnung wieso reddit steckdosenleiste das motor da
gibt es doch bestimmt welche steckdosenleiste können noch geflasht werden excellent letzter
mod was warum finde ich wenn ich reddit suche warum finde ich dann einfach shellys kaufen
ich würde mir einfach shellys kaufen aber shellys haben keine steckdosenleisten shellys
haben steckdosen und relays und gedöns aber keine steckdosenleisten smart wie heißt das
auf englisch power strip oder so heißt das was was heißt steckdosenleiste nicht strip
oder heißt das strip
reddit das motor
innerhalb von einem jahr jawoll
finde mir mal eine ja super ist doch miss können bei der gelegenheit gerade mal gucken vielleicht
oh nee jetzt habe ich auf chinesisch umgestellt oder irgendwas ach du kacke da wollte ich gar
nicht hin oje
ah wir sind wieder weg
manche manche chinesen verkaufen nämlich schon preflashed das motor
das sind meistens keine steckdosenleisten sondern nur so einzelne geräte ach das ist
doch alles mist so zweitreich ich hätte mir damals gleich 20 stück kaufen sollen von
den koge steckdosenleisten leute 20 stück dann hätte ich nie wieder steckdosenleisten
gebraucht ich habe das ding noch vor er warum ist das auf deutsch wieder hab das vorhin
schon auf englisch umgestellt als er uns was von von von lustiger witziger wolke erzählt
hat wo wir uns doch gefragt haben was ist das für eine übersetzung
dieser power strip genau
oh nee kakona steckdosen
was zum teufel macht der typ da
was ist für den chinesen los wieder
warum machen die das nasus stecken an fieberthermometer rein
nee das ist kein fieberthermometer jaja es ist klar
na klar
die schreiben natürlich nicht rein ob da ein esp drinne ist aber das ist natürlich auch
eine schwachsinn also es ist wirklich schwierig steckdosenleisten zu finden die
kogik das sieht das sieht er doch erstaunlich ähnlich nur dass die usb dinge anders an
die habe ich bestellt die habe ich bestellt
die habe ich bestellt und die ging nicht
die konnte ich nicht flaschen ich habs probiert
by the way wie kommen die eigentlich auf 4000 watt 16 mal 230 sind
was weiß ich irgendwie 3000 noch was aber aber bestimmt nicht 4000
plus usb nee nee das ist einmal
eigentlich was du maximal also das eigentlich maximal 16 ampere machen aus allen geräten
dann
demnächst steckdosenleisten chip für esp tauschen ja
oder sind sie auch noch zu teuer
das ist wirklich schlimm also steckdosenleisten gibt es echt keine
wie sieht es denn wie sieht es denn mit sig b steckdosenleisten aus gibt sowas
gibt es sowas ich meine die müssen ja definitionsmäßig funktionieren
schnäppchen oder mogelpackungen
das sig b zeug kostet immer gleich doppelte von allem anderen
guck mal bei amazon sig b steckdosenleiste
das sind alle auf template lieferbar sind ah nice excellent excellent
ja die haben wir eben schon gesehen die ist mir zu teuer gewesen
die ist nicht mehr flaschbar das haben wir eben gesehen in comments
ich gehe davon aus dass die alle nicht mehr flaschbar sind
ja genau die haben leider die haben leider irgendein realtech chip jetzt ziemlich kacke
tint von müllerlicht ok wie schafft man das eine steckdosenleiste
zu machen die so beschissen bewertet ist ich meine das ist eine steckdosenleiste mit
irgendeinem sig b drinne das nur bedingt smart was haben sich die
entwickler da gedacht zuerst mal von den 2 dosen relays gespart
oder was
es lassen sich nur 2 steckdosen schalten das auch nur zusammen
was ein schwachsinn mann das braucht man nun wirklich nicht
gibt es seawave steckdosenleisten ich sehe schon
also ich muss ich muss die hegen und pflegen meine kogeek tasmotake steckdosenleisten
pinst nix mehr kannst vergessen
das ist echt bitter ich hätte ich ärgere mich jetzt richtig ich hätte mir einfach
noch irgendwie wirklich ein zwanziger pack oder so bestellen sollen
wäre ruhe gewesen das ist wirklich doof
echt zed ja zedge
manche leute sagen es zedge anstatt zedge ich sage zedge
wieso kann man tasmota nicht mit einem anderen chip machen
weil tasmota eine customfirma ist explizit für esp 2866 und esp 32
wenn die irgendeinen realtech chip drinne haben ist das komplett andere
architektur drunter und nicht kompatibel also es ist einfach auch binary mäßig
gar nicht lauffähig warum willst du die flashen dass ich nicht
die china app brauche und dass es komplett ohne internet geht
und ich besser in meine heimautomatisierung integrieren kann
das ist doof tasmota realtech port ne das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht sehen
zumal tasmota auf dem arduino
aufsatz von diesem esp sdk basiert das werden wir nie im leben auf
irgendeinem anderen chip sehen
ne das ist schon 2 jahr her das wird nicht funktionieren
ach übrigens ich hab gestern vielleicht hat das auch einer von euch
hat irgendwer von euch freeguy geguckt hab ich gestern geguckt
falls es bei amazon auf ist ist jetzt neu bei amazon gab und ich muss sagen ich
fand den film gar nicht schlecht ich fand es echt nice leider das einzige ich
ich spoiler nicht ich spoiler nicht ich spoiler nicht ja keine sorge aber eine
sache die ich nicht gut fand und das ist kein wirklicher spoiler zur story ist
der wie soll ich sagen der bösewicht ich ich hätte lieber ein ich hätte
lieber einen gehabt er war so hipster ich hätte lieber einen gehabt der so typisch
bvl stonks mäßig aussieht weil das wäre einfach realistisch gewesen ja aber
ansonsten fand ich den film nicht schlecht war seit langer zeit mal wieder
irgendwie ein neuer film den ich gut fand
ich mein pokimane und sonst wie streamer die da drinnen vorgekommen sind zwar
halt irgendwie hardcore cringe und keiner wusste so genau was die da
machen eigentlich geschweige denn leute die den film gucken und und nicht im
internet unterwegs sind keine ahnung was da überhaupt geht aber gut aber es
wurde geteep act was auch niemand versteht denn ich weiß was es ist welcher
film den ja die hatten da so szenen drin die halt so ausgesehen haben als würde
es gelivestreamt und so total blödsinn eigentlich das war das war der einzige
grinch teil für mich an dem an dem film dass sie eigentlich real life streamer
da drinnen hatten
gibt sie auf steckdosen leisten
cream also das ist ja so komplett nicht das was man in bild sieht also die
beschreibung und der inhalt könnten nicht weniger zueinander passen
sechs steckdosen leist und man sieht ein was ist denn das überhaupt den
klinge anschluss auf lightning ist es schlecht vielleicht vielleicht als der
hersteller einfach verkackt vielleicht gibt es ja wirklich noch
brennstuhl
das hammer ding wie gesagt dass das das von hammer ist original die steckdosen
leiste die ich auch von kogik kogik habe aber die ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
flashbar außerdem sind mir 36 euro zu viel für so china chinesen kram
aha aha ja moment das motor taugt von 2020 das glaube ich euch auch dass die
2020 das motor fähig war keck weight september 2021
hmmm eigentlich sind die mir zu teuer aber
aber in anbetracht der tatsache dass ich echt gerne noch ein paar tas motor
steckdosen leisten haben würde link ich kann den link ins chat posten hier aber
wie gesagt ich kann nichts dafür wenn die nicht dann doch flashbar ist
ich bestell mir jetzt vom handy aus eine bam amazon ich krab mir jetzt gleich ein
und gucke ob die noch hammer beladen steck kann überschreiben steckdosen
leiste bei mir kostet die auch nur 31 witzigerweise jetzt kostet wieder 36
jetzt check ich nimmer ist vom foto koch schickt mal link ich nehme die auch
billiger kein problem nach hier unten neu ab dann aber mit
versand oder dann bestimmt mit versand wenn der foto koch am start ist der
foto koch mit 25 näh das ist natürlich doof kostenlos lieferungen 37 lohnt sich
nicht so ich bestell mir die jetzt einfach bei amazon liefern am dienstag
jawoll ins basket check out bei nah ich werde die da auch nur ganz vorsichtig
aufschrauben dass ich im zweifelsfall wenn kein esp drinne ist amazon
zur schicken kann so was mache ich natürlich nicht
lul
er hat einer china china chinesen zeug gepostet naja moment einfach nur fix da
sein und aus ist das nicht das problem dass ich habe auch kein problem ein bisschen
länger drauf zwar die sieht ja mal mega beschissen aus alter sieht das ding
scheiße aus also die haben sich auch gedacht ich muss jetzt mal ein youtube
comment zitieren wie hässlich soll die steckdosen leiste sein ja alter sieht
das scheiße aus das sieht aus als hatte man ein gehäuse wurde es nicht richtig
reingepasst hat was ist ein alter sich dass das sieht das sieht schäbig aus das ding richtig schäbig
alles in ce aufkleber die tschibane uns natürlich aber die ist bestimmt nicht
flashbar wichtig ist dass die flashbar ist das bekommt man bei aliexpress schnell
schlecht raus suchen wir mal was wie heißt der hersteller
da weiß ich ja mal ich suchen soll
sieht okay aus nee ich finde die sieht richtig hässlich aus aber wie kacke
das sieht aus als passt das gehäuse nicht zum rest
ja wie heißt der hersteller kann ich wenigstens mal danach suchen
seota alles klar ja man weiß es nicht man weiß es nicht die haben sogar das handbuch
hier drinnen und da steht nichts drauf außer dass es gegen den tujas trip ist aber das ist ja auch
klar smart leben nicht funktioniert mit alles alles klar aber dick mahr smart leben funktioniert
oder bin ja froh dass alles dass alles nicht geht aber dick mahr geht treibt die irgendwie
einer was zu flaschen das sollte die heißt wirklich seota wirklich krass gar nicht gedacht
konfigure stoller ps 22 das sieht aber echt nach dem aus
ist schon mal ein bisschen billiger
versendet nicht nach germany aber kostenloser versand 22 ja das jetzt das ist jetzt echt gut
glück ob die neue version noch das motor flaschbar ist oder überhaupt ein esp hat oder nicht
man kann ja auch hier nicht gescheit durchsuchen
das kaufe ich mich außerdem sieht das das ding kacke aus gefällt mir überhaupt nicht
gut genug genug zum thema steckdosen leisten lasst mal kurz weiterschauen ich muss mal kurz
das haben bestellt aliexpress stellt haben wir auch schon gemacht d1 mini haben wir gemacht module
haben wir gemacht ich brauche eine neue fernbedienung für mein schiel tv die hat aussetzer und das
liegt nicht an den batterien das ding gibt glaube ich langsam den geist auf die fernbedienung
nicht das schiel tv gibt es da irgendwelche sinnvollen billigen remotes für an door neun
euro remote oh ja die ist bestimmt die ist bestimmt top und wie kommt man auf die ideen
der fernbedienung unten rund zu machen so dass sie nicht liegen bleibt und erst mal fünf
minuten schwingt die akkus haben dasselbe problem bei mir kommen batterien rein und
mir kommen batterien rein in das schiel tv fernbedienung und an den batterien liegt es
nicht also ich habe die batterie auch schon öfters gewechselt mit multimeter nachgemessen
also die sind ok die fernbedienung meldet sich auf bluetooth mäßig immer ab und wird
da nicht mal gefunden und das ding ist ziemlich im arsch ich gehe davon aus neue fernbedienung
gut ist mobile die normale fernbedienung das sieht billig aus
ich habe ich glaube ich habe auch 2007 aber kein pro oder wahrscheinlich also ich habe
ich habe da kommt so eine knopfzelle rein ja die da von der fernbedienung her nur dass
es nicht grün leuchtet der 2017er one for all streamer remote ja 19 euro das sieht doch
sinnvoll aus was wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe warum hat nvidia das schiel tv von einer
eigentlich ganz netten schwarzen box zu so einem komischen zikarettenanzünder jetzt
umgebaut ich meine das schiel tv an sich davor das sah ja durchaus ok aus das sah
so aus und jetzt ist das so ein komischer zikarettenanzünder mit einer dreieckigen
fernbedienung also weiß nicht was man sich da beim design
gedacht hat da verstehe nicht vor allem warum muss es dreieckig sein so dass du es nie richtig
greifen kannst oder was oder chat erhält mich mit euren design kenntnissen warum macht man
eine dreieckige fernbedienung das ding sieht doch ganz gut aus smart tv smart devices wat ich will
einfach nur ein ding fernsteuern fernsteuern und gut ist ok die übertreiben sie aber oder alter
wie viel knöpfe will ich haben jawoll gibt mir mehr knöpfe never ich will auch keine
drei geräte haben ich will einfach nur ein gerät haben moment ist das überhaupt bluetooth
als die schiel tv ist fernbedienung ist er glaube ich bluetooth gibt es da keine app dafür
aber das handy fernsteuern ich weiß nicht hipster also ist das bluetooth
le oder was geht das so genial scheint das ding nicht zu sein ja dann weiß ich auch nicht also
all school iger keine fernbedienung ok ich wollte gerade sagen doch all school iger gehts immer noch ok
das ist das ist eine fernbedienung wie vor 1990 einfach nur schön fett und sieht übrigens genau
so aus wie die fernbedienung bei meinem fernseher dabei war nee cc ist nicht so geil zum bedienen
ich weiß dass es eine neue ist die sieht genauso aus wie von meinem fernseher die die sieht genauso
aus wie von meinem fernseher ich habe ja auch in sony fernseher und die sieht halt auch richtig
all school aus ok amazon was kannst du uns empfehlen fernbedienung in massen
ordentliches werkzeug gut aber das set habe ich schon brauche ich nicht noch mal das ist
halt der vor und nachteil von gutem werkzeug zugleich wenn du das gekauft hast das hält
eine weile gut ich glaube das mit den fernbedienungen wird jetzt nix
kannst du nur multimeter empfehlen um ehrlich zu sein nein kann ich nicht ich hab eins und ich
bin damit eigentlich auch halbwegs zufrieden das ist aber so ein bisschen besseres china ding
es ist jetzt nichts was ich unbedingt empfehlen würde übrigens wann ist eigentlich dort noch
ganz random wann ist eigentlich dort net 6 release das müsste auch jetzt bald eigentlich sein
9 november das heißt nächste übernächste woche
übernächste woche da müssen wir uns ein stream machen wo wir uns die neuen sachen angucken
was ist dort net 6 programmierumgebung was hältst du davon dass man seit märz 2019
da könne ich mich auch jedes mal drüber aufregen da könne ich mich auch jedes mal drüber aufregen
erinnert sich noch jemand an diese abstimmung zur zeitumstellung wo alle gesagt haben ja
na gut alle nicht aber wo der großteil der leute gesagt haben weg mit dem scheiß und man kriegt
es nicht gebacken das ist für mich sinnbildlich dazu was die eu für ein riesen verwaltungs was
für ein riesen langsamer verwaltungsapparat dieses ganze monst drum an auswüchsen mittlerweile hat
die anderen pech wenn die nicht zur umfrage gehen dort wo abgestimmt wurde die haben alle
überwiegend gesagt sie wollen das die anderen abstimmen ist es nicht mein problem oder nicht
hingehen ja ja das ist immer da sind sie immer schnell dabei ja ehrlich gesagt mir ist die
zeit egal hauptsache es gibt eine einheitliche aber das verstehe ich auch nicht also wenn das
nicht hinkriegen kann das ist irgendwelche lego fletschens geschichte keine ahnung gucke
ich nicht ich vermute mal anhand dieser geschichte dass es lol ist so ein bisschen was sagen mir
die begriffe ja aber ansonsten kein schimmer das finde ich auch kacke das ist mit der zeitumstellung
dass wir das nicht auf die reihen kriegen so ich muss mal kurz gucken was da noch mit einkaufen war
haben wir ja dann iphone 11 brauche ich noch aber das werde ich jetzt hier nicht bestellen
was kosten der kram eigentlich mittlerweile für weihnachten brauche ich das was kosten der kram
eigentlich mittlerweile ist es jetzt billiger geworden vielleicht ein bisschen keine ahnung hier
da weiß schwarz wie auch immer rot gelb gelb grün banana ein 579 euro ok also kostet das immer
noch das gleich und ein post leid zahlen liegt also kostet das immer noch das gleich na gut da
wäre ich wohl den sauren apfel beißen müssen aus wo man sollte das wohl vom ist moment warum
kosten das so viel warum ist das so schlecht lieferbar aber hier kann man sich in iphone
11 kaufen a general überholt oder teurer you got she baited ach nee das ist auch die 128
g version das hier ist die 64 g version 64 gb aliexpress nee nee nee bei amazon kann man
immer noch bestellen schwarz was zum teufel ist mit denen los man what the fuck
aber findet man findet man bestimmt findet man bestimmt irgendwo noch günstiger
ich laber ein scheiß wieder ich meine ich günstiger lieferbar
klingt müde ja ich bin müde bettgetein bald boomer müde schon spät
ich glaube das war es an einkaufen was ich am start habe hier
ich brauche noch arbeitshandschuhe für einen garten das ist jetzt nichts was wir
irgendwie großartig zusammen kaufen müssten steckdose haben wir geguckt remote haben wir
geguckt ach ja was kostet mittlerweile ich habe ja gehofft dass es ein bisschen billig wird billiger
wird die roborock saug saugstationen oder in kombi kosten da kram mittlerweile gibt
es das überhaupt hier zu kaufen ja das ist nur die absaugstation
was ist denn mit was ist denn mit der mit der seite hier wieder los ganz oben
ich checkt es nicht das ist der wahnsinn das auf jeden fall es ist auf jeden fall relativ teuer
899 das ist sehr ordentlich also nee am dark reader liegt das nicht am dark reader liegt das
nicht es ist gerade es ist gerade broken anscheinend das ist google ist gerade kaputt aber 899 ist
doch ordentlich teuer was ist mit dem preisschamp wieso was soll damit sein noch ist er an aber
nicht mehr lange der preisschamp kommt demnächst weg ich habe keinen bock mehr daran weiter zu
entwickeln und vor allem der crawler ist nicht so schnell was deutsche shops angeht und selbst
da ein pflegen will ich nicht also wahrscheinlich gibt es dann immer lange gibt es den open source
wann kommt web der stellt wir könnten tatsächlich den nächsten tagen wieder was machen weil ich
habe endlich mal weiter gemacht an meiner camera software weiter zu basteln für die wir so ein
tolles logo entworfen haben das logo dieses logo ein quality logo ich gehe mal davon aus wenn das
einer sieht das wird ihn sofort überzeugen das zu verwenden wenn er das als logo erkennt
er das als logo sieht aber das ist von letztem jahr wo ich da was gepusht habe
der object detector was habe ich da überhaupt wie alt ist das eigentlich was
habe ich da gemacht kamerastream pur keine ahnung was stark gebastelt habe
ja oder bin ich gerade dabei ein bisschen ein bisschen weiter zu bauen ich habe da
nämlich einen grund grundlegenden denkfehler drin vielleicht push ist das demnächst auch
ist die gegensprecher lage bridge fertig ja ist fertig aber abgespeckt weil ich festgestellt
habe ich will gar nicht mit den leuten unterwegs reden ich habe es jetzt nur so gemacht dass ich
auf dem handy das video sehen kann ohne mit den leuten zu reden weil manchmal interessiert
mich was da abgeht aber ich will unterwegs gar nicht mit den leuten reden ich mache es
jetzt einfach so dass ich wenn ich abnehme dass halt instantes video bild kommt und dann kann
ich unterwegs also ich bekomme ja einen anruf wenn es klingelt an meiner tür gegensprecher
lage und mittlerweile bekomme ich halt nicht nur den anruf sondern hat dann auch das bild
von der kamera an der tür aber unterwegs ich habe nicht also wir haben es ja im stream sogar
schon eingebaut dass man mit der gegensprecher lage vom handy ausreden kann aber das habe ich
nicht weiter verfolgt weil ich habe mir mal gedanken gemacht und ich benutze das gar nicht
aber bild sehen ist ganz praktisch dass ich wieder sehe ob dhl den kram übern übern oder amazon
dhl ist es ja nicht dhl schmeißt die packchen teilweise auf die straße und amazon schmeißt
sie übers hoftor beides nicht so sinnvoll ja leute wir können es noch ein bisschen laberstelz
machen wenn ihr wollt wenn es irgendwelche interessanten sachen gibt dann schießt los ansonsten
bin ich mit einkaufen fertig ich habe das ja hauptsächlich gemacht dass ich jetzt ein vorwand
habe und ihm um den stream anzuschmeißen aber waren ja doch ein paar ganz nützliche sachen dabei
schauen wir paar youtube videos machen wir morgen früh doch schon weiß nicht was es da was es da
gibt level cap jebaited uns mit battlefield 2042 ich muss noch ein battlefield video aufnehmen so
ist der battlefield 2042 halb tot fragezeichen brauche ich einen guten titel für wie viel uhr so
morgen früh immer immer zur gleichen uhrzeit also immer immer wie immer wie immer also sprich
irgendwann so 99 oder 30 10 uhr oder so ist auch nach nicht zeitumstellung keine ahnung
aber ich meine irgendwelche sinnvoll aktuellen fragen oder irgendwas was ihr wissen wollt
dazu kann ich nichts sagen kannst mich auch genauso fragen was ich von den griechen und den antiken
römern und so halte ja das ist glaube ich heute nacht anwenden die uren umgestellt oktober 31 oktober
ja warum ist das eigentlich um drei uhr wahrscheinlich weil da die meisten leute
statistisch sind schlafen magst du eigentlich eine freundin nähe das natürlich ich habe da
keinen bock drauf auf zeitumstellung eine umstellung ist echt das unsinnigste überhaupt
das video haben wir schon geguckt max hörst du den busket nein ich kenne das und ich kenne
auch ein paar sachen von das ist nicht wirklich meins obwohl ich vom alter her eigentlich genau
passen müsste da gibt es noch nicht so viel zu programmieren ich habe die ehrlich gesagt auf
vorrat gekauft wenn ich geräte die on board linger austauschen will aktuell gibt es da
nix außer ich kaufe mir noch so eine zweite smarte ventil auf zumachgeschichte mit motor
dann vielleicht dann könnte man es mal ausprobieren wobei ich keinen bock habe noch mal 35 euro
auszugeben und es dann zu grillen ich brauche einfach mehr prime subs ich habe prime subs
kriegen kann ich mir von den prime subs den ganzen krams kaufen und dann muss es mich auch
nicht ärgern wenn ich kaputt mache das ist die idee so sollten wir das machen gibt mir einfach
alle euren prime subs dann kann ich unsinnige technik von amazon kaufen die ich dann uns
tremen kaputt machen kann beste idee kommt verdient besaß doppelt es gibt kaum was besseren
für den wie wenn ich mir von prime subs amazon sachen kauf überlegt euch das doch mal wenn
man von dem geld was man von prime subs bekommt amazon zeug kauft ich mein besser geht es doch
für besaß echt nicht da kann er ins weltall fliegen wobei waren nicht schon oder wie war
das da war er doch schon oder macht auch patreon nee als nächstes also was ich auf jeden fall
mache ist und das mache ich noch vor ende des jahres ich mache youtube memberships hier
auch mit den mit den keksen und so hat mich überzeugt die abo falle hat zugeschlagen
eigentlich dafür den subs law für die subs leute hier möb skill killer dokter hau mich
blau exzellent ja ich weiß aber trotzdem ist das für mich der amazon mensch
das spiel bestimmt kein new world
ja dann kann man nichts machen
danke für die subs
der stream startet zu der zeit die dann aktuell ist also 9.30 meine ich 9.30 wenn morgen 9.30
auf der ur steht
so lange für den sub jetzt geht es aber los ich sage euch leute die jetzt jetzt seid
ihr in der abo falle drin jetzt ist nicht mehr mit anzahmen vorbei
müsst ihr bis ans lebensende prime subscribers sein bei mir
das ist hier so so schneeball system quasi
vielleicht kommt das gemtrain war da nicht vorhin schon mal
oh es war jetzt was hat er gemacht was hat er gemacht
hast dich verklickt
er ist gesagt wird er gebannt alter
mords haben sich verklickt mords haben sich verklickt da müsste es ich hoffe mal sie
haben sich wieder an brennt
probiere mal aus du müsstest wieder da sein
und ich müsste jetzt der chat müsste wieder gehen
denn so wie bei den chinesen sieht es aus
jetzt hat jetzt habt ihr ihn verdrieben
eine jetzt hat jetzt hat er die sperre aufgehoben jetzt kannst du wieder schreiben
mords sind auch bettke mords hatten die augen wahrscheinlich kratz und irgendwie random
in den chat geklickt
das ist auch doof dass es da keine ich habe auch schon mal leute aus versehen
timeoutet dass es da keine abfrage gibt wenn man jemand bant wollen sie wirklich
dass man quasi so in so einem safe mode hier aktivieren könnte das wäre eine praktische
funktion geht wieder alles poggers
ja naja
na gut leute also dann gibt es ja jetzt nichts mehr anscheinend dann sehen wir uns morgen
früh wieder ich schau mal kurz ob es irgendjemand gibt der nicht hosten kann
keiner darf von den leuten den ich folge
na gut dann leute wir sehen uns zu macht's gut was alpha 4 games
was macht er denn auf twitch gerade was macht ein alpha 4 games auf twitch
zeig mal her
mario kart double dash
ja double dash das ist ja schon richtig oldschool kram
muss ich mal followen wusste gar nicht dass der auf twitch am start ist
na gut leute wir sehen uns bis denn
zu